I think innovation is going to be key to
health care and if you say to me what's
going to solve the health care problem
it's going to be innovation there are
different kinds of innovation there are
innovations in medical devices and drugs
and so on many of them add to expense
but they may improve health by quite a
lot there's another kind of innovation
that we haven't that doesn't get touched
on as much which i think is worth
highlighting which is innovation in the
way we go about providing medical care
there was an old TV show Marcus Welby
that probably the older listeners who
have seen in the people and the younger
viewers will not Marcus will be practice
medicine I think was the 1950s or so
there is nothing that is done in the
medical system today that Marcus Welby
would recognize no procedure no pills
nothing but he would completely
recognize how medical care is delivered
it's a doctor in an office with a
patient and that's what happens so
almost nothing is the same in the world
today as it was in the 1950s accept the
fact that we go about providing medical
care in the same way let me just take
one example of why that is so harmful if
you look at patients with chronic
disease diabetes or hypertension or high
cholesterol many of them do not take the
medications that the doctor recommends
because they don't know what they're
supposed to do or they have side effects
and they don't know how to deal with
them it's very easy to help them nurse
practitioners can help them physician's
assistants that does not have to be a
doctor we do not pay for that we do not
recognize that we do not allow that in
most circumstances and the result is
that those people are not treated well
they wind up with complications with
very severe effects afterwards and the
whole system dysfunction is poorly we
need a health care system that's focused
around helping the patient and if that
means that there's a nurse practitioner
who's there to help you out a great if
that means that that there's a
physician's assistant or a group visit
with lots of other people figured out
how to do that then that's what we have
to enable
so far we almost prohibited we don't
help it we're not even neutral we
basically say we're not going to allow
that which is just a huge huge mistake
and it's something that's going to have
to be have to be very different or else
we're never going to make a lot of
progress
a lot of the innovations in health care
recently have come from a couple of
places one is the kind of analyst
community where there's been a wholesale
change in thinking since since the the
past reform effort 16 years ago where
you know have much more attention
information technology and how you'd
eliminate waste and so on none of what
you saw and then the what's very
interesting is the provider community
has a number and insurer community for
that matter has a number of very
progressive elements groups that are out
there saying you know what we're just
not going to tolerate patients getting
substandard care care that's not as good
as it should be and so you have the male
clinics and the cleveland clinic's and
the kaisers and the group health
cooperatives and the Health Partners and
those guys and your health care's and
the Intermountain health care's and
Virginia Mason all of those examples
those are companies that said and their
insurance companies that provider groups
there dr. groups they said you know what
we are just not going to take it anymore
and many of them put themselves at
financial risk by doing better that got
in situations where they were preventing
readmissions to the hospitals enough so
that they nearly went under and some of
them had to go begging and pleading to
Medicare saying can't we work out some
arrangement where when we improve
quality and lower costs we don't suffer
so much and that's actually provided a
lot of the example that we have so it's
not when we talk to people now about
health care reform it's not hypothetical
it's real it's this works and we see at
work and you can have it too and I think
between the kind of analyst thinking and
what's going on at the most progressive
places you really have this this this
model out there and this framework for
what to do which is very very helpful
do parts have to go together the
covering people in the modernizing the
health care system you cannot do one
without the other in Massachusetts we
covered people without doing anything
about the cost we decided we wanted to
cover people first and we deal with the
cost later now we are stuck dealing with
the cost the system costs more than it
then we know how to finance just because
all medical care costs more than we know
how to finance so we've got to come back
and we're now trying to deal with the
cost in the national level people talked
about saving money first and then
covering people but nobody wants to see
the implications of a health care system
that tries to save money when they're 50
million people without coverage and
another 50 million people who are eating
out of coverage during the year would
just be an epic disaster so they have to
go together the key to it is has got to
be innovation